marie maude denis bienvenue à enquête
[Applaudissements]
la nuit descend sur la route 181 au nord
du nouveau brunswick autour de nous la
silhouette régulière des plantations de
conifères
une forêt artificielle sur laquelle on
pulvérise chaque année des dizaines de
milliers de kilogrammes de glyphosate
les grands-mamans d'en donner le
contrôle de notre forêt publique aux
grosses compagnies le but d'une
industrie c'est de faire des sous puis
c'est d'avoir de faire des profits
puis on sent que c'est peut-être à
n'importe quel prix cette histoire parle
de pesticides mais aussi d'exploitation
de terres publiques d' influence de
censure et d'une petite communauté
acadienne du nom de kedgwick
depuis 25 ans la famille harper organise
des expéditions de canot sur la rivière
restigouche son eau limpide est reconnue
mondialement pour la pêche au saumon
cette région splendide attire des
milliers de touristes depuis des
décennies certains cas tout ce qui vit
autour de ce qu'on veut la protéger
on veut en prendre soin prendre soin de
cette région est devenue pour eu de
combat
à moins de 5 km de leur maison le
paradis de francine lévesque et d'andré
harper se transforme en un paysage de
désolation
jusqu'à une centaine de camions de bois
défileraient ici chaque jour
j'ai juste besoin dans ma cuisine je me
lève la tête je vois les camions et des
camions venant des camions en route ça
finit pas par quoi je me suis dit il ya
une façon ça se peut pas ça se peut pas
été limités l'industrie forestière est
un secteur crucial de l'économie du
nouveau-brunswick et génère des
retombées de presque 2 milliards
[Musique]
cette petite province et celle qui
pulvérise du glyphosate de façon la plus
intensive sur les forêts publiques au
canada
le biologiste marc andré villard observe
attentivement l'écosystème de cette
forêt depuis des années quand on survole
le nouveau brunswick on peut très bien
voir que chaque hectare de forêt ou
presque est aménagé et c'est un mode de
foresterie comme on disait qu'ils
étaient très intensif peut-être le plus
intense et fo canada cette forêt story
intensive viennent avec deux pratiques
controversées la coupe à blanc encore
quasi systématique au nouveau brunswick
avec tout ce qu'elle entraîne des effets
néfastes et une arme chimique le
glyphosate en forêt on appelle un site
aussi on le pulvérise chaque année sur
un moyenne qu'ils mail hectares de forêt
coupé pour tuer les feuillus et
favoriser la pousse des conifères plus
rentable pour l'industrie un outil pour
les uns un poison pour les autres
j'ai pas besoin d'un bac en biologie
puis on s'en faut restaurer pour pour
savoir c'est 80% des échos au niveau
mondial c'est de la coupe à blanc puis
là tu bien distincts l'arrosage on
arrose unc points 30 % par année mais ça
s'accumule nous aurons une terre ce qui
est arrosé il ça fait 20 ans 25 ans et
ya rien qui possède encore si ces
féminines aux pilleurs
entre 2013 et 2017 cette région était
une des plus arrosés de la province pour
nous dit souvent qu'on arrose encore une
fois mais il ya plusieurs parcelles qui
sont à ruser deux fois et parfois trois
fois
c'est ce qui a amené des gens des quatre
coins du comté de restigouche a formé le
groupe eco vie ils sont inquiet pour la
santé de leurs forêts et pour celles des
gens qui vivent à proximité
ils ont de mauvais souvenirs à l'époque
du ddt concertation pleine et ce prix
jag au rose les roses le matin à 5
heures avant qu'elle va sur canal et
travaille à la faveur de st lô et celui
ci du glyphosate
bush par des ans dans un champ voisin
en commençant ma polonais spa boon êtres
humains fossard sa secte les bassins
versants
donc c'est important ce 2-2 de faire
attention parce que la petite goutte
d'eau qui tourne dans le monde ont fini
dans la rivière piché le concours
d'entrée vers un monopole des finesses
et c'est pas toi que la nature nous a
donné une dose on voudrait que ça soit
respectée
et kobe a vu le jour dans la cuisine de
charles thériault candidat du parti vert
aux dernières élections provinciales
ce documentariste a produit une série de
vidéos sur l'état de la forêt publique
il me semble que c'est pô juste l'abus
l'arrosage beaucoup de controverses il a
été un des premiers à remettre en
question la pulvérisation on veut on
mettre fin parce que partout autour du
monde on commença reconnaît que le
glyphosate un impact incroyable sur
notre santé et sur la santé de notre
forêt surtout que ça tue tout bio
diversité pour être capable de garantir
le profit de compagnies sa conjointe
betty saint pierre est une extrême aïeux
en forêt conseille d'arroser sa tante
pas d'aller ramasser de noisette
puis quand on voit que c'est un cap très
arrosé des femmes'' de ramasser les
petits fruits
selon lui c'est poli ou bi charles et
betty voit la forêt se transformer sous
l'effet de son exploitation est ainsi je
dirais même que 15,7 à passer en dessous
mots sous bois je mettais plein de
mangeoires à oiseaux puis j'en avais des
centaines puis aujourd'hui si j'étais
toi quatre oiseaux à maman joueurs je me
trouve chanceux
l'arrosage tu es tu de façon efficace
ça fait des années que des citoyens
réclament la fin de l'épandage sur des
terres publiques sans parvenir à faire
fléchir l'industrie les deux camps il ya
des gens qui ont une idéologie il ya une
perception de la forêt puis c'est
difficile à changer cette idée
moi je regarde surtout dans une façon
oui commercial mike légère et directeur
général de forêt nouveau brunswick la
voix de l'industrie dans la province
tant que lé gouvernement approuve le
glyphosate dit il
l'industrie est en droit de s'en servir
on fait attention on lit la mode
d'emploi on suit les règles et
règlements
l'application puis d'épandage ce qu'il
faut ça c'est triste et moi contrôlés au
niveau du fédéral puis aussi niveau
provincial
même s'il est approuvé
l'épandage du glyphosate a un impact non
négligeable sur l'environnement croit
marc andré villa
le biologiste enseigné pendant 22 ans à
l'université de moncton
mais c'est dans la forêt acadienne qui
l'a mené ces travaux
il s'est demandé jusqu'où on peut
exploiter la forêt de manière aussi
intensive sans compromettre son
potentiel de conservation
au delà d'une certaine proportion on va
compromettre la richesse de la
biodiversité et on comprenait certains
processus écologiques
par exemple nous on s'est rendu compte
qu'il ya des espèces d'oiseaux qui
freinait carrément leur mouvement
al'approche des plantations qui
refusaient ou qui semblait éviter de se
déplacer à travers les plantations de
conifères la forêt a besoin de cette
richesse pour se maintenir et se
régénérer et c'est même dans l'intérêt
de l'industrie afin qu'elles restent
exploitables mais les craintes du
biologiste ne sont pas partagées par
l'industrie ça va revenir ça prend à peu
près cinq sets
la biodiversité dans des plantations
s'affaisser fosse à dire qu'il y en a
pas ce n'est pas tout à fait ce que les
travaux de marc andré villa ressemble
indiqué résultat c'est qu'on en ferait
est très contrastée avec des plantations
qui sont très simplifiée par rapport à
la forêt naturelle donc par rapport à la
biodiversité c'est ce que ce type de
traitement lors des impacts prince père
marc andré villa n'est pas le seul à
contredire l'industrie brad copeland a
payé durement le prix de ses positions
sur l' usage du glyphosate en forêt pour
lui c'est devenu une bataille très
personnel
on veut des gens qui ont le courage de
leurs opinions
ce qui semblera redon et les gens qui en
ont ils se retrouvent au chômage
car s'en prendre à l'épandage
d'herbicides au nouveau brunswick n'est
pas sans risque
[Musique]
world comes around a découvert ce qui
arrive quand on attaque l'industrie
forestière de front au nouveau brunswick
pendant 15 ans il s'est bâti une solide
réputation à titre de biologistes de la
faune au ministère des ressources
naturelles
il suit la population de chevreuils et
les ravages les endroits où ils se
réfugient l'hiver mais quelque chose
d'imprévu ce produit
[Musique]
tout d'un coup la moitié des ravages
sont déserts on s'est tous demandé
pourquoi personne ne connaît
le biologiste s'attend à trouver des
chevreuils là où la forêt qui a été
coupé se régénère naturellement à ma
grande surprise les deux tiers des ondes
de régénération où aurait dû se trouver
des chevreuils et est maintenant des
plantations arrosé derby
et on le sait l'herbe et si tu les
feuillus et les broussailles précisément
ce dont les chevreuils ont besoin pour
se nourrir
une fois arrosée selon lui saison
deviennent trop pauvre pour les
chevreuils
il restait seulement 15% de nourriture
convenable pour les chevreuils
j'ai compris qu'on avait un sérieux
problème les biologistes est convaincu
d'avoir trouvé une des raisons qui
expliquent l'exode des chevreuils ça
représente 32 mille tonnes de nourriture
pour les chevreuils
c'est l'équivalent de 300 camions bennes
ça signifie qu'on pulvérise en un an ce
qui pourrait nourrir le tiers de la
population de chevreuils
c'est considérable dès qu'il prend sa
retraite
broadcom berline commence à renaître
publiquement en question usage du
glyphosate
le biologiste voit ces données mise en
doute on lui reproche ses attaques
irresponsables l'accusation vient de
djezzy un vignes le plus grand joueur de
la province loin devant le reste de
l'industrie forestière une des familles
parmi les plus riches au canada elle
détient des intérêts entre autres dans
le pétrole et dans les médias irving
gère plus de dix mille kilomètres carrés
de forêts publiques et défend ses
pratiques non seulement relever une
tienta ces pratiques
l'entreprise forestière veut plus
d'accès à des zones de conservation
traditionnellement réservée à la
protection de l'habitat pour la faune
on parle de forêt qui se sont régénérés
de ravages de zone tampon de parcelles
qu'on préserve pour protéger la faune
ils ont coupé tout le reste sauf ce
dernier 30 % de forêts il voulait y
avoir accès le pouvoir de la famille
irving semblent considérables dans une
lettre adressée directement au premier
ministre
levine laisse planer la menace de pertes
d'emplois s'il n'obtient pas accès à des
zones de conservation
il se plaint de la résistance opposée
par le ministre des ressources
naturelles bruce northrup à son projet
quelques semaines plus tard celui-ci
s'était montré la porte du ministère à
dompter le gouvernement capitule un an
plus tard dans un protocole d'entente
que le gouvernement a d'abord gardé
secret ils s'engagent à assurer la
viabilité de leurs vignes et à revoir
les zones de conservation en fonction
des besoins de l'entreprise
[Musique]
les néo brunswickois apprennent des
semaines plus tard que les zones de
conservation sont réduites à 23%
c'était clair et net qu'il y avait
effectivement une influence majeure de
la compagnie ministre le contenu de
nouveaux plans d'aménagement vignes se
réjouit faut de la forêt façon très
responsable et nous montrer bon accord
en travaillant avec les les ovocytes est
l'un de ces universitaires et justement
le biologiste marc andré villar qui
siège au comité scientifique consultatif
de jenni erwin mais qui ne voit pas les
choses du même oeil c'est à ce moment
qu'elle critique le nouveau plan
publiquement je sentais que le le le
la balance elle est vraiment du côté de
l'exploitation intensive sur les terres
publiques
et quand on parle de terres publiques
moi ça me concerne comme comme chercheur
certainement comme citoyen aussi mais je
me suis exprimé comme chercheur parce
que j'avais effectivement des données à
long terme sur les effets de la
foresterie intensive
quelles ont été les conséquences avocat
évidemment sans surprise j'ai été éjecté
du comité
après l'éjection de marc-andré vilar
après le limogeage du ministre c'est au
tour de la médecin hygiéniste en chef de
perdre subitement son emploi le
gouvernement évoque un cas de ressources
humaines mais cela survient juste au
moment où elle se penche sur l' usage du
glyphosate l'indignation du public monte
d'un cran quand la vérificatrice
générale critique à son tour le
gouvernement sur des pratiques
forestières élan dénoncent le coût élevé
pour les contribuables
ces grands moments qui payent pour
l'arrosage depuis le début parce qu'on
veut aider l'industrie est renta
l'arrosant j'ai payé par nos taxes qui
sort c'est une chose de se payer son
propre poison là ça fait pas d'eux aucun
sens le mouvement d'opposition prend de
l'ampleur dans la province le groupe
arrêtons l'arrosage voit le jour à son
tour mais il y à un autre moment décisif
en 2015
le centre international de recherche sur
le cancer classe le glyphosate
cancérigènes probables l'industrie
réplique et lancent de concert avec le
gouvernement
le site info forêt point ca pour éduquer
la population sur le glyphosate
c'était pourquoi on a fait ça c'est
incroyable comment ce que les gens sont
tellement bien formés là dessus puis
c'est quand prenable sais c'est pas des
gens qui travaillent dans la forêt c'est
pas des experts puis des fois il va
former les opinions qui sont fondées sur
des informations
il faut forer ses puits sur un expert de
renom le professeur émérite de
l'université de guelph la nourriture un
discours rassurant qui a des allures de
déjà vu au canada
ça fait plus de 60 ans qu'on pulvérise
des pesticides sur les forêts
canadiennes un des plus dangereux a été
sans conteste le 2 4 5t contaminées avec
des dioxines impuissant cancérigènes et
du riz
c'est un des ingrédients entre autres de
l'agent orange rendu tristement célèbre
pour son usage par l'armée américaine au
vietnam
les etats unis l'ont banni à la fin des
années 70 mais santé canada a continué
de l'approuver jusqu'au milieu des
années 80 en avait profité pour un
acheté 800 gallons pour les épandre sur
les forêts du nouveau brunswick un des
toxicologues à santé canada à l'époque
s'appelle laine retour pendant sa
carrière
le toxicologue reconnu mondialement par
ses pairs a souvent défendu l usage des
pesticides et d'autres produits
chimiques ce qui lui a valu des
critiques acerbes
par exemple quand l'ontario l'a choisi
pour mener une enquête sur des
travailleurs exposés à l'agent orange au
coup de vieux au prix de 12 mois qu'il
faisait
vous êtes au courant
ce retour est quand même monsieur
controversé dans son milieu c'est sûr
quand tu travailles dans ce domaine là
que tu vois tu irais lara controverse
c'est normal le nom de la nourriture
apparaît dans lemon santo peppers ces
documents internes révélés au public
lors de procès retentissant aux états
unis le professeur fait partie d'une
liste d'experts sur qui monsanto dit
pouvoir compter pour défendre le
glyphosate
il est décrit par le fabricant comme
quelqu'un qui livre les interprétations
et les messages qu'on veut mettre de
l'avant sur ce sujet les navetteurs n'a
pas répondu à nos courriels elf aux
forêts s'appuie aussi sur des chercheurs
du ministère fédéral des ressources
naturelles qui défendent la position de
l'industrie
certains leurs travaux ont été financés
par des fabricants d herbicide de
monsanto et si que par un ring cpauch du
normal
beaucoup de scientifiques qui sont qui
sont souvent sur leurs recherches et
souvent sonné pour des compagnies je
crois pas que ça que ça démontre que
comme scientifique que ça va créer un
juge et dans leurs recherches
le site omet toutefois de divulguer des
liens de ces chercheurs avec monsanto et
avec un film dans le passé le biologiste
marc andré villa ne cache pas que
certains de ces travaux et ceux de ces
étudiants ont été financés en partie par
revenus mais ces fonds ont été coupées
lorsqu'il a été éjecté de son comité
scientifique revient n'a pas voulu
commenter la compagnie n'accepte pas
certain point de vue et veut contrôler
ce qu'il dit publiquement
même si on a comme professeur chercheur
la liberté académique
donc ça c'est pas acceptée par la
combine
le site info forêt ne fait aucune
allusion à ses travaux sur l'impact
négatif de la foresterie intensive sur
la biodiversité
info forêt point ca
c'est de la propagande c'est un site web
créé pour dire aux gens que tout va bien
avec le glyphosate en juin dernier
broadcom belinda été congédié du collège
de technologie forestière des maritimes
où il enseignait depuis sept ans un des
motifs du congédiement
on m'accuse de saper la science dans le
séminaire sur la gestion de la
végétation
les gens ne réalisent pas que ce qu'on
me reproche c'est mon point de vue sur
le croiser à feuilles un ex directeur
général du collège a admis avoir fait
l'objet de pressions du conseil
d'administration à son époque pour faire
taire les faits reprochés à l'ancien
directeur qui enseignait toujours au
collège a été congédié à son tour pour
avoir divulgué des informations
confidentielles précise l'établissement
sans plus de détails
wattecant rowland est aujourd'hui dans
une situation précaire
il vit de petits contrats et juste c'est
une cause bien des problèmes
j'ai perdu ma couverture d'assurance à
rené pacte sur ma retraite
broadcom hollande ne regrette rien l'
usage de glyphosate en foresterie est
loin d'être exclusif au nouveau
brunswick
presque toutes les provinces canadiennes
accepte cette pratique sauf au québec où
les citoyens ont mené une longue
bataille pour le faire bannir bien
malgré l'industrie
[Musique]
au retour on vous explique pourquoi le
québec a banni l'épandage d'herbicides
sur nos forêts
[Musique]
la dernière forêt naturelle autour de
romont avant l'heure
je vois que j'ai écrit au ministère
puisqu'il accompagne et qui m'a répondu
c'est pareil comme devrait rejoindre
avait créé au bon dieu il ya 20 ans le
documentaire choc de richard desjardins
a profondément changé la culture
forestière au québec
ce qu'on oublie c'est que bien avant le
québec avait adopté une usure quasi
révolutionnaire à l'époque la fin de
l'épandage aérien de sitôt side
moi je pose la question pour procès
était bannie pourquoi vous pensez
c'est la politique je crois que c'est le
même affaire qu'on rend compte au
nouveau brunswick
c'est du populisme les gens sont
tellement convaincus ils sont un peu
aveugle à les autres informations ne
veut pas tout considérer si voire pas du
tout pas du tout on a fait nos devoirs
écoutez on a entendu 200 de mémoire on
les éplucher j'ai jamais travaillé fort
comme ça luc bouthilier est un peu
l'homme derrière cette décision
il était commissaire au bape le bureau
d'audiences publiques sur
l'environnement qui a recommandé la fin
de la pulvérisation des phytos id
la mesure est entrée en vigueur en 2001
avant d'en arriver là les québec avait
eu sa part de dangereux pesticides
pulvérisé sur les forêts ce qui est
sorti en audience le jet pas en train de
nous refaire le coup du ddt ou du 2
capté du 2 4 5 t24 t24 5 t de ces dix
cousin de l'agent orange où on disait
ben y'en a pas de problème la végétation
venez puis il ya pas d'impact persistant
sur la santé puis un usage l'on s'est
rendu compte au nom qui en avait
jour après jour
le bape a entendu l'industrie
agrochimique des forestiers des
scientifiques des environnementalistes
mais aussi des citoyens comme son mandat
l'exigent et on est obligé de dire
bombay lost une inquiétude qui nous
apparaît again manifeste majoritaire et
non seulement ça elle nous apparaît
fondée au québec
la pulvérisation aérienne a été remplacé
par du dégagement mécanique plus coûteux
mais qui a créé de l'emploi
l'arrêt pendant ce que j'ai à sort c'est
que ça ne marche pas cela marche pas de
notre économie ça ne marche pas dans
notre province
au nouveau brunswick
l'industrie se dit est capable de rester
compétitives sanli fiducie des
conséquences
je peux garantir que si on a beau lac
c'est un outil comme la griffe au sat
oui d'homère on pourrait arrêter
complètement mais il ya le programme qui
sera présenté
ça se voit résulté dans un manque de
bord assez bois pour fournir trop s'il y
une usine à pâte à papier
avec un emploi sur 14 qui dépend de la
foresterie dans la province la menace
des pertes d'emplois créés beaucoup
d'inquiétude dans les communautés qui en
dépendent
on va pas se débarrasser d'un instrument
on veut qu'à comprennent que ça marche
plus la façon que ça a toujours
fonctionné puis on en grand donner notre
point de vue là dessus oui on est en
rage et puis oui on veut que l'arrosage
arias pinon on n'arrêtera jamais de
gueuler on va y aller tant qu'on n'aura
pas réussi à gagner le point pourtant
manifestations pétitions même une motion
au parlement
rien n'ébranle le gouvernement dirigé
depuis 2018 par un ancien chef de
l'exploitation chez hurling ailleurs
charles thériault n'a pas peur des mots
quant à lui la province et captive de
l'industrie on dirait aussi que la
population vit ce qu'on appelle le
syndrome de stockholm a éventuellement
tu arrives à accepter puis tu considère
même que ton carter est un personnage
bénévoles ans qui va un ton bien même si
tu es capturé puis en seulement six
coups nouveau brunswick suppose or pour
être capable de maintenir sa job elle
capable de nourrir sa famille même si
des fois c'est difficile on est mieux de
fermer sa gueule puis rien à dire est ce
que vous considérez que vous avez
l'acceptabilité sociale pour le faire
encore
je dirais présentement c'est en question
surtout au nouveau brunswick
je perds ma tête en sorte j'entends les
arguments des gens je comprends qu'il y
en a qui sont sans sincèrement inquiéter
le meilleur qu'on peut faire c'est les
les offrir les informations que nous
avons mais pour luc bouthilier ça ne
suffit pas c'est pas une démarche ou de
quelqu'un qui prend son bâton de pèlerin
et qui dit écoutez moi bien les enfants
alors voici comment ça se passe
je vois vous expliquer sur comme il faut
et surtout faites moi confiance s'est
passé à l'acceptabilité sociale ça on
appelle ça des relations publiques
[Musique]
le team arguments des opposants c'est
qu'il faudrait à tout le moins exercé le
principe de précaution comme l'a fait le
québec
bon je trouve que trop souvent des
groupes qui sont opposés à la foresterie
ou n'est pas que n'importe quelle sorte
exploitation des ressources
il joue la carte de la principe de
précaution trop souvent lorsque l'on
parle du l'argument c'est la seule chose
qui reste quand pas la certitude
scientifiquement pas dans d'autres types
d'options qui sait ce devrait être pour
lui faire ça aujourd'hui on fait un
voyage nature
ben si on peut appeler ça la nature à
kedgwick la forêt acadienne continue de
se faire roger petit à petit plein de
gens qui ont des chalets sur des lacs et
tout on avait toutes coupes à blanc
autour d'eux en arrière de tout ce que
tu veux
mais en plein coeur de la région le
gouvernement a accordé un statut de
protection à une importante part ces
lieux ce qu'on a ici
adams coach c'est le camp priver de pain
derby le chalard règne de paul ouin ici
le chalet des farines la province leur a
donné 1 200 ha de zones protégées autour
du chalet
[Musique]
en quittant le nouveau brunswick on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de se demander si la
forêt publique appartient toujours au
public
avec nos collègues de la semaine verte
nous avons préparé un dossier complet
avec tous nos reportages à l'adresse
radio canada.ca barres obliques
glyphosate
[Musique]